[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream what we are now
calling the post Joe Rogan experience
all right
so we're calling it I don't know it
seemed to me at that moment that that's
what we should call it but in any case
we are here this is our 24th live stream
I am sitting with dr. Heather huiying
and there is as has been the case for
months now a lot going on in the world
yep which is part of why we started
doing these but first today is the
Solstice it is the Solstice is the
solstice it is the summer solstice here
in the northern hemisphere the winter
solstice for those few people who are
watching and live in the southern
hemisphere meaning it's the longest day
of the year
it is the year during the moment during
which also our twilight's are actually
lasting longest as well for the same
reason that's the longest day of the
year so first day of astronomical summer
historical midsummer so Shakespeare's
Midsummer's Night's Dream was about this
moment not a month and a half from now
yeah you alerted me to this fact before
I had not thought about it but it makes
a great deal of sense that what we call
summer would actually have moved and we
are now talking about in the same way
that we have altered the meaning of time
to become like laboratory time rather
than time the way humans experience that
we have altered summer to be this solar
solar definition rather than either
defining it around the way the seasons
actually happened where you are or
defining it where the maximal day length
would be the middle of that period we've
defined it where it starts at this
period where day legs begin to shorten
yeah are we I mean we could it could be
defined midsummer could be the solstice
right and that would also be
astronomically global I mean that would
be a truth that was applied to the whole
earth but you know this nature of
seasonality is so
varied depending on where you are on the
planet I remember growing up in LA as
you did as well hearing these aphorisms
like april showers bring May flowers
thinking I don't think it's ever rained
in April in LA I used to shower in April
yes you see if I could get flowers there
and any effect nothing yeah the only you
know the seasonality in LA the Santa Ana
winds that come in and September and
October and start fires there's there's
no aphorisms about that so summer
solstice is a reality it's a it's the
solstice everywhere on the planet winter
solstice in the southern hemisphere
summer in the northern and and here we
are now the days get shorter but slowly
but the days also get warmer for a while
so all else be thoughts being equal this
is the point where you have the maximum
opportunity to produce vitamin D per per
day yes this is that point which ever
more evidence suggests that that is
something that you might want to be
doing right now given that it seems to
be protective against coronavirus yes
it's something you should want to do for
lots of reasons this makes you much
healthier and less vulnerable in general
but with respect to kovat 19 might be
particularly important incidentally I
ran across something on this front as
long as we're talking about daylight a
recent paper reflects that one of the
hypotheses that we advanced and talked
about turns out to be right which is
that one of the reasons that czars co2
is not transmitted outdoors as easily as
indoors in fact vastly less easy is that
apparently UV light is highly
destructive of Sarrus co2 so we now know
that for a fact which opens the
possibility if that's the only factor
then it suggests that outdoors might not
be so safe at night whereas if it's one
of a couple of factors like we've talked
about the other factor that's probably
highly relevant is the airflow and the
volume AB solute volume of the air in
question so we're developing a kind of
model in which for some reason instead
of a virus being able to get into you
and infect you there's some level at
which you can absorb these things not
specific
quickly they're dealt with maybe by
macrophages or something and at the
point you've overwhelmed the macrophages
then you are in jeopardy and in an
outdoor environment the dissipation of
these things and if it's daytime the
destruction of them in the sunlight
makes it unlikely you will cross that
threshold whereas indoors it can happen
in a five-minute conversation if
somebody's sick and expelling virus
towards you and I think I think most of
our intuitions if we've spent any time
in the physical world are pretty good on
this front I'm remembering as you talked
about I was in San Antonio in November
of last year and I found myself having
dinner one night an outdoor restaurant
but it was in a little alley between two
buildings and I had been very eager to
sit outside because I always am unless
conditions are stifling in some regard
but because it was really narrow between
two rather tall buildings
I had the sense that the air wasn't as
fresh as I wanted it to be and you know
given what we know about these
transmissions inside you know interior
restaurants of the coronavirus where
people sitting it's sort of in line of
the HVAC flow end up getting infected at
much higher rates and those people
outside of that of course if you're in
some kind of an urban jungle outside
probably isn't going to be as protective
as if you're in an outside space with a
lot of airflow as well so I've got a few
of these parameters to wrestle with
absolutely and we have indicators from
history that people have intuited
certain things sometimes incorrectly so
I believe that both plague and malaria
have been attributed to stale air in the
historical past before the proper term
theory of disease told us what was going
on in the case of malaria malaria is
exactly what it means it's not really a
question of air volume it's a question
of mosquitoes which inhabit swampy kind
of air and in the case of so they just
got it the at a gross level and an
imprecise level the observation is kind
of accurate right like if you're hanging
out in an area with stagnant water that
tends to produce stagnant air air that
smells of the an toxic stuff that it's
emerging from you're more like a dead
mosquitoes around which are which are
the things that vector malaria right
it's inaccurate but there is an
observation that's real at the base
it's also true that in the case of
plague which at least in the the
majority of cases is transmitted by
fleas mm-hmm you're also talking about a
place if you were in some dank place
where you know there were rats
I mean rats in particular have a smell
that you can detect walking into a room
so there is some sort of indicator in
the air and it's not that you're
smelling fleas but nonetheless it's good
enough the sense that that's maybe not a
smell that you want to hang around is
and at some level both of them are
indicators of kind of you know trust
your nose trust your senses yeah if
something is telling you back off just
like if you run into decaying you know
roadkill or pile of feces your
everything in you says don't get closer
to that yeah those intuitions are built
around that which of course also fits
with our sense of beauty perhaps being
an indicator of lots of proxies for
things that are useful or valuable or
tend to imply opportunity or whatever so
anyway what a shock that we are well
designed for environments in which our
senses can detect things that clue us in
to hazards we may not be able to name or
describe and that many of us feel more
afield than maybe we even recognize our
ancestors would have because
so many of us are not even living now in
the environments in which we grew up not
only are aphorisms our cultural norms
built around places that most of us may
not live at the moment but our
developmental environment is not a match
for our current environment and so we
are we are we are simply out of touch
with our own selves in a lot of ways
yeah we are out of our depth in an
environment that we have largely created
yeah so well wait before before we move
on from the Solstice I want to say one
other thing which is there's there's
some facts about the Solstice and other
celestial events that I think need to be
said out loud because we just the lesson
is not it's not well taught in general
and I'm gonna interrupt you and say that
you I mean we but this was this is one
of the things that you led when we used
to teach together you created a workshop
that grew every time with god I
shouldn't I wasn't prepared for this but
you know three pages of questions like
sing
line questions like you know tens and
tens closing it on a hundred questions
that you asked students to figure out
you know what what they knew about it
and whether or not they actually knew or
if they were just accepting something
they've heard everything from you know
what is the solstice to why our seasons
and you know what our tides what our
tides and why are there two high tides a
day that's the one that's the one that
was most stumping yes he most yeah the
most stifling yeah so what I wanted to
say was that a I hope the religious
folks in our audience won't take this
the wrong way but there are certain
facts about the universe that really
strongly suggest that one of two things
has to be true either the universe was
not designed by an engineering entity
that wanted all this to happen or it was
and that entity didn't like us or want
us to succeed so one of them is that the
number of days in a year is not an
integer but it's close yeah and because
it's close what that means is that for
cultures that try to figure out how long
the calendar is they can't nail it
because they tend to be one day long or
one day short at least and when you do
that you tend to think for some number
of years that you've got it right
because the vagary is the noise of
weather obscures the signal that you
would detect as a slight shift every
year of you know if you put the right
data plant is this day it won't be way
off for twenty years maybe right and you
won't be able to detect it because of
the you know the variation in the
seasons weather weather is noise to the
climate underlying it right and so
anyway cultures around the world have
there been to two things done one is you
try to calculate it better and better
and eventually you discover that it's
not an integer and you figure out what
to do about that and you insert
something like leap year in order to
correct for the slight shift right which
is incidentally why this year right now
the Solstice is on the 28th rather than
the usual 21st this year is a leap year
and so we had the 29th that got in the
way and we're ahead other than that yeah
we would be on the 21st as it usually is
although really the Solstice is a moment
in time not a
yeah so it's a mmm 5:30 p.m. something
today anyway and so we celebrate short
years three years and four yeah um okay
so in any case cultures have figured out
another way to deal with this which is
not to go after the precision which is
so maddeningly difficult to nail but
it's to actually go empirical and so
you'll find all of these clocks built
into yeah into you know mountainsides
and structures circular structures in
which you know on the Solstice the Sun
comes through this window and you know
lights up that corner actually I should
have brought a picture of the Qunari
version of this but I am but anyway
there's there all of these calendars
that are physical calendars that don't
need to be calibrated because they are
physical and the lining up of several
things allows you to actually know what
day of the year it is so long as you
don't have cloud cover right well but I
mean you can still as it approaches yeah
you know if you're sort of tracking it
but so there it is the basic point is
the calendar has been frustratingly
difficult to nail down it's actually
very late emerging that we have a good
answer to how long the year is that we
can actually hang our hat on and many
cultures have worked around that by
going empirical and it's left all of
this beautiful architectural evidence
yeah all over the world and you know a
lot of it is convergent this isn't
necessarily cultures getting it from
each other they're discovering the same
problem and solving it in the same way
yes
there's certainly multiple evolutions of
it we know them at Inga perco which is
this qunari inca sort of collaboration
in ecuador is obviously independent from
stonehenge right and there are many
other examples that are independently
evolved arrivals at the same way at the
same problem the same Universal human
problem of how is it that we figure out
what this planet is that we're living on
and when to plant really I mean there's
a I'm sure that there are other reasons
that early humans that you know
prehistory humans just meaning before
humans were writing needed to be
accurate about the time of year but
agriculture is a huge one yeah right
and so we can expect that these sorts of
empirical ways of telling time over the
course of a year probably started to
emerge
eight ten twelve thousand years ago in
the various places where agriculture
started to emerge at exactly the same
times and again independently several
evolutions several independent
evolutions of agriculture across the
world about ten and twelve thousand
years ago
and so actually final point this also it
actually tells us something about our
current moment there's something about
the internet and all of us interacting
across arbitrary distances and time
zones and all of that it's actually very
disorienting on the one hand it alerts
you to something true about the fact
that you're on this planet full of
people for whom it is not the same time
of day and they may be in the opposite
season but it is disorienting in the
sense that once upon a time and not so
long ago what where you were seasonally
was not so much a question of the
calendar that we all share was a
question of how the calendar interfaced
with the particular ocean currents that
were near you or whatever and so I've
always been troubled for example by the
fact that we synonymous autumn with fall
my sense is fall is the period when the
leaves are falling right and that varies
a lot it's not and it in LA for instance
there is no fall really there's not
unless you have you know elemental
there's no one fall because the trees
come from all over the place in a
pre-columbian LA there was no fall right
yeah yeah so anyway it just the the fact
of you know even the discovery of time
zones is is an interesting fact and
until then and the question of what time
it was
it's a little odd because you know you
don't have to ask because it's obvious
what time it is
at least you know yeah during the day
most days well I mean actually Zack
our producer and older teenage son just
reminded me of something that he learned
in history this year in which which I
knew as well which is that it was
actually the advent of trains across the
United States that forced cities and
states and presumably the federal
government to actually make uniform time
because otherwise there was no need for
it but if a trains come in a particular
moment and you need to pick someone up
you need to catch a train
you actually all need to agree on what
time it is and what that means there's
no need for it because horses are just
not fast enough even at a horse crossing
space you don't have a disturbing
discontinuity whereas we now have well
but I think boys huh more to the point
you don't know for sure the horse is
gonna arrive at 4 p.m. you can say I
expect to be there before dark you can
send a letter and say I'm hoping to be
there before dark on the Saturday of the
Harvest Moon or whatever it is but
there's not there's not a horse
scheduled the way there is a train
schedule that's not really true you know
in in the 16th century
ok proto-fascist used to make the horses
run on time which was famously oh yes
yeah right
ok Oh Zach says he thinks it was also
about making the trains not crash so it
was an aesthetic isn't certain yeah I
think so yeah these little trim niggling
concerns ok so you went to LA yes I did
go to LA and actually I must tell you I
had not been on a plane exactly you want
to talk about that a little bit cuz that
that is that was the first time either
of us had travelled since February yeah
and I wouldn't have done it if it wasn't
very important you know joe rogan is is
a special phenomenon and so it seemed
worth doing in light of what's going on
in the world and the opportunity to talk
about it with Joe to his audience but
the act of getting on an airplane was of
all the things that I've seen I think it
was the most different from normal
right the experience from one end of the
to the other of the airport of the
airplane everything was bizarre and
although in some ways you know the
airport was wonderfully empty at some
level it was you know it was a calmer
space and my plane Zach do you have the
video can you put the video on that I
took of my plane ok so we'll show you a
video of what it looked like
see very few seats are full leather
flayed it would have been fun yeah this
flight would have been jams hacked on a
normal
so anyway it's a very different and
jarring experience in as much as lots of
aspects of it the more comfortable I
have to say sense that something must
have gone very very wrong for a plane to
look like this during a normal flying
period was it just never lifts you're
constantly reminded that something is
way off I mean you're you're enclosed in
your face mask yeah one thing in fact I
wore not only my band and I were a
double facemask thinking that this was
about the most dangerous thing I had
engaged in since recirculated air yeah I
cannot escape from how they do say
before you get on the plane there now
like these uh screens that broadcast
information tell you that the air is
HEPA filtered I couldn't get anybody to
tell me for sure whether that was normal
and they're just telling us about it now
or it has been added nobody seemed to
know but at the moment it's broadcasting
this information and all of these things
are are and that should I mean that
should do it right this is a big virus
that should HEPA filter filtration
should do it well if it was the virus
alone it wouldn't be enough but the fact
of the virus travels in water droplets
really the virus alone would not be
caught by have the filter is that right
I think that's right
very smell that there isn't there is a
number I forget what the scale is gold
but so anyway I also in both directions
my flight was either canceled or the
plane was changed there's a lot that's
just not functioning very well in this
system so there is that but yes I went
to LA and LA is also very off it's just
coming out of lockdown so there's
beginning to be traffic again and things
like that but it's rather surreal out
there I'll bet so and if you want I
guess I'm curious and maybe most people
wouldn't be if they don't know la well
but the idea of an LA without traffic
strikes me is not really la you know in
a much a much improved environment but I
think you know earlier in the lockdown
we were hearing that the streets were
empty and kids are playing ball in the
streets and and such and is there is
there anything else you want to say
about you know the experience of moving
through LA
as it emerges from lockdown you know the
thing is there's not very much reason to
move through it so so you just went to
where you go it's sort of you know
wherever you are you're probably
experiencing and what you face I wish I
was there with you but South Korea right
are they completely free I'm not sure
actually I'm not sure but yeah you're
somewhere on pause some kind of pause
and that experience varies a bit but the
weird sense of you know things happen in
one place and it can disrupt the
functioning of a city but for the world
to be this way at once is very strange
yeah
so you were invited by Joe Rogan to go
to go back on your fourth fifth this
time third time alone I believe and
early in your talk with him you said
that you had been struck by police twice
in your life and the story that you told
on air actually is when I had I had not
heard and we must have been living
together at the time because the only
time you lived in Berkeley was when we
lived in Berkeley together you said that
you joined protests against homelessness
in Berkeley because you supported the
cause but you hadn't even known it was
happening like just wiped through it and
I just bikes down there yeah exactly and
having joined it you were promptly
smacked by a cop with a baton yeah cop
knocked me down with a baton amazing me
tell you know you think I was do I to
remember couldn't say no I'm I think I
would remember that I think you would
too
yeah so you had your bike with you no no
I was on foot yeah - I was moving the
crowd was moving towards the Berkeley
campus and I was moving with them and I
ran into this cabin I you know I I
remember other people get smacked down I
just you know no only was personal
it was awful yeah but and it alerted me
to this sort of sense which is you know
it was the first place that I really
understood okay all I had to do to be
this cops enemy was to just be in favor
of this cause and March this direction
yeah this has nothing to do with my
behavior right I was just I wasn't it
was a peaceful protest you were marching
towards the campus you said
was a loud peaceful protest okay but
loud like angry loud or musical loud
chanting loud not that it matters say it
was I mean you know it's a long time ago
that's it yeah my memory is dim but I
would say it's it was loud and angry
okay but it was what it was nonetheless
I didn't you know I didn't threaten
anybody I wasn't
breaking anything I was just going in
that direction mmm-hmm and so anyway
that was that yeah yeah
so you said well there were two Joe said
were they and you said well the first
one is a long story from my first
research gig in Jamaica and you then
skip to the next one and it didn't come
back up but I'm thinking you might want
to tell that story because this one no
this is the the revenge best served live
isn't it you're gonna have me tell that
story here I think I think it's it's
fascinating I think I at least watch
that and thought oh like I know the
story and I still want to hear it all
right well let me see if I can put the
story back together so I was I guess it
would have been 20 this is when this is
when you were you spent seven weeks in
Jamaica with Bob Trevor's yeah Bob
Trivers is a great evolutionary
biologist who's a good friend of ours
actually he was the officiant at our
wedding
yeah um after long after this event but
so this would have been 90 probably 1990
fall of 1990 fall of 1990 so you would
have been 21 21 years 22 okay so I was
in Jamaica extended period of time I did
not know in what manner I would be
staying I was 91
sorry probably 91 91 okay so I went with
Bob to help him with research on lizards
that he was doing Bob is a guy of
European descent but he prefers to live
with black people he identifies as black
before that was ever a thing um so
anyway he lives in Jamaica and he was
married to Jamaican woman he's divorced
but he has kids with her and so he's
still a member of their family and
anyway I went down to research with him
and I arrived and he picked me up at the
airport and I at that point discovered
in
way I would be living in Jamaica he just
said he would take care of it he hadn't
told me a thing and it turned out that I
was living with his family that one of
the daughters of the family was away in
the states with her husband and so her
room was free and I stayed in in her
room and and this is his mother-in-law's
house right yep misses his former his
former mother-in-law is Nene yeah and I
would say in some sense one of the many
things I learned from my time and to
make it was that effectively the divorce
Bob that Bob's divorced from the
daughter didn't really change anything
because they were related through the
grandkids and so anyway so bob was still
part of the family even though he and
the daughter no longer had a romantic
relationship right exactly so in any
case I was staying in her room and the
this family so I'm sorry yeah you
weren't staying in Bob's former wife's
room you're staying one of the other
daughter's room one of the other
daughter's rooms right now and so anyway
Jamaica's warm climate this is by the
way off in the country right this is in
Southfield Jamaica which the only place
that you might know about if you're not
from Jamaica that you would have heard
of that was anywhere near by his lover's
leap lovers leap is a famous Vista where
I think two people were supposed to have
committed suicide together lovers who
couldn't be together and there may
actually be an interaction with slavery
in that story which I have now forgotten
but but in any case lover's leap is a
famous place South field is near it and
when I was in Southfield it was
primitive enough that there was no phone
I had I brought a bike with me so I
could ride to the junction to call you
since you and I were already involved
and committed to each other and so I had
to have a bicycle to get to the junction
because there was gonna be no other way
to make contact with you regularly so
anyway and that was ten or fifteen miles
away I don't know what the state of
Technology is there I would imagine it's
changed a lot but in any probable as we
saw a first-hand in Madagascar that
cellphones moved in and then landlines
never happened
so probably people have cell phones that
could well be could well me what
happening here it's a good prediction
but anyway so I was staying in this
house and the house is a house but the
kitchen is outside there's technically
running water which involves pumping
water that's collected from rain off the
roofs
out of a big pool under a so there's a
big pool collects water off the rooms
and then you pump it into an air tank
above the house and then that feeds the
running water but for some reason that
wasn't up and running but there you know
there were outhouses and you took a
shower by dropping a bucket into these
big pools and you tried not to knock the
bottom out of the bucket when you did it
which was difficult but anyway you would
do that and you'd pour water over your
head to shower and so anyway it was that
kind of thing but the yard was basically
the center of a community right this was
a this was a it was a clan a group of
people who were affiliated in one way or
another not just the family itself and I
became good friends with Lexi and Prince
who were somewhere near my age and
anyway it was very interesting to be you
know to be friends with people who were
living such different lives but anyway
we got along really well and it was a
tremendous amount of fun so here's we
get to the difficult part of the story
this time in my life I smoked pot pretty
regularly and I was in Jamaica and pot
is very unstick Mathai z'd in Jamaica
and I wanted to have some and I didn't
want to be sourcing it a little bit at a
time so I and it was also that what this
image of that being pulled I wanted to
have some and I didn't want to source it
a little bit well don't forget this was
your idea for me to tell the story so
anyway so pot was cheap there it wasn't
especially good it's what we wish called
ditch weed yeah right but it was
plentiful and so anyway I so you could
either buy it a little bit at a time or
you could buy way more than I was going
to need so anyway I
I think I threw 100 bucks of the problem
or something and I ended up with 10
times what I would have needed and so I
I had a maybe an ounce of it and I had
given the rest to my friend Lexi and
anyway I was there and things were good
and I was researching with Bob and I was
learning a ton about how other people
exist in the world and all of this and
anything about lizards and about lizards
and as my time and to make it was
drawing to a close one night I had gone
to bed just like I would any other night
and really late like 2:00 in the morning
would be my recollection I hear a very
loud thud and I wake up and I think I
don't know what that is and suddenly I
hear a lot of shouting and there are men
streaming into the house and these
officers obviously police officers
dressed fully in riot gear military gear
they were heavily armed multiple
automatic weapons are coming through
shouting about something I have no idea
what the hell's going on I'm just
sitting there stunned right I didn't I
mean frankly I probably hadn't seen a
cop in Southfield it just was you know
it was a little outpost somewhere and
suddenly these cops from who knows where
and anyway one of them comes into my
room and he I cannot do it Jamaican
accents very difficult acting he says
you know there's one white brother in
here and then there's like a commotion
what does this mean anything like that
it so anyway I'm sitting there and he's
standing in the doorway and it's clear
that I'm supposed to stay still and I
stay perfectly still and they go
streaming into the other rooms and I'm
afraid because although pot is not a
prosecutor defense in general in Jamaica
it's still illegal right and I know that
there's probably half an ounce of pot
under my bed all right yeah you know in
a little paper bag and anyway they kind
of search the room haphazardly and you
still have no idea why their ID
have not called them there no idea I'm
just don't I could I can't even imagine
because there's nothing there's nothing
about this family nowhere at this point
you have any idea how the rest of the
family is doing right like you're you're
trapped in your room the cop is saying
you stay here or no making it grow all
pinned down but everyone's pinned down
you don't hear commotion doesn't sound
like people are being dragged off but
you can't tell right and so okay so they
cop does a cursory search I think I
detect that he does not find what is
under my bed and I breathe uh kind of a
half a sigh of relief and they go into
the next room over which is Lexi's and
boom they find the pot under his bed or
wherever it was or whatever and they
lead him out in handcuffs
hmm and you know I'm thinking holy crap
what's going on here and so anyway the
cops finished their search of the house
they're messy and raucous and you know
they're probably are they destructive
mm-hmm they're definitely like they they
turn the place over but I don't know
they don't stuff yeah
not intentionally I mean they break they
break non-physical things yeah they
break trust and such and there must have
been you know we got our glimpses it
must have been ten or fifteen cops
several vehicles was crazy so anyway
they stream out and they take Lexi with
them and you know in handcuffs and they
disappear into the night and we're
Alexia's had one of how many young men
at the house at this point well that's
the thing other than you so Lexi and
Prince would have been the two you know
older guys um Bob's son Johnny was there
but he's young he's young he's quite
young so anyway it was me and later than
like because we net and spent some time
with Johnny when he lived with Bob in
Santa Cruz for a while a couple of year
later he was like 11 or 12 yeah kid so
so anyway Lexi and Prince were there but
Prince was actually staying at the
neighbor's house house-sitting so he
wasn't there and it was the only young
Jamaican man yeah yeah so okay so we're
all only Jamaican man gets it's taken
off and goes and anyway we're looking at
each other thinking what what just
happened
and we like the woman of the house and
you Johnny
and Nene and maybe there's a woman Karen
who didn't live right there but she may
have come over but anyway we're looking
at each other not quite sure what to
make of this why it's happened what's
gonna happen to Lexi we don't know and
so anyway as soon as we get our bearings
Johnny and I decide that we have to go
tell Prince what's going on um you know
his best friend has been hauled off and
you know whatever it's just the next
imperative thing is that he knows what's
going on so Johnny and I head off and
you know the houses are probably 150 200
meters apart they're not right close to
each other yeah and anyway we walk off
across the night and my recollection is
we get to the door of the house where
Princess House sitting and I am like mid
knock and hands grab me away from the
door and suddenly I find myself up
against the wall facing these cops they
were going to how did you like how did
you not know they were there well that's
the thing were they were they've quiet
somehow yeah either they were they saw
us coming and maybe they'd left the cars
I don't I don't know what they had done
but for some reason we were there
stealthily I'm surprised yeah so they
grabbed Johnny and me and ninety-two yes
oh yeah and they have us up against the
wall and I realize oh [ __ ]
I had just thrown on clothing from you
know the day before and in my pocket
there's a joint and a lighter and the
cop is searching me mm-hmm
and he reaches into my pocket and he
steals my lighter and misses the joint
all right like letters maybe a rare
commodity in Southfield they are a
fairly rare case you know it's an object
of value so anyway I breathe another
sigh of relief and the cop is being
rough with me
yeah he's roughing me up a little bit
rough with Johnny too as far as you know
yeah both of us and I am NOT happy to be
roughed up I and so I'm trying to reason
with him I later have a conversation
with Bob about what I should have done
but nonetheless I'm trying to reason
with them I'm trying to be decent and
all of the things that you would do to
get a cop to stop doing this to you and
it's not working and at some point I
curse in Jamaican and ice so I say Ross
clot right and the cop knocks me to the
ground right kaboom
alright who's his arms or does he have
it he grabs me and throws me to my gun
and and I'm stunned this is not a normal
occurrence in any way I kind of get back
up and he tells me to stay there quietly
and they go in and they searched the
house and I don't think they find
anything in this house and they don't so
they don't take prints away
they don't take prints away and then
they disappear into the night and
they're gone so you think stealth was
right go back to the house and we confer
and and then you talk to Prince - yeah
oh yeah
absolutely I think at this point and
this is the moment for me to ask you
what Bob told you you should have done
or do you want to oh yeah so what does
Bob say later you should have done
before you continue oh I said I should
have gone into a upstanding American
citizen proper English mode that I would
have basically not tried to be of the
population I should have emphasized
being outside of it that's that's
telling yes it is tell us basically
basically he's saying you know this is a
man who was lived with an among and as
family in Jamaica most of his adult life
who's basically saying as you have you
use your privilege honorably use it when
you can
so that you can help those who don't
have it just as long as we're here and
since these things are on Wikipedia
anyway Bob Traverse was a black panther
there's some story that I think I don't
know about why he was I think he was
kicked out of the Black Panthers for his
own good but but I think he was still in
the Black Panthers at the point that he
actually had as a graduate student and
graduated with a PhD Huey P Newton Huey
Newton was he had a PhD in biology I'm
gonna tutelage ABAB driven evolutionary
biology yeah yes I think that was after
the Panther fee and Huey remained close
okay and so anyway he remained close
with the Newton family is as we saw when
we were friends when we were living in
the same place with him in the early 90s
long after well at least somewhat after
Newton had been killed
yeah so his admonition was not it was a
practical piece of advice it was not out
of love for the police because obviously
the tension between the Black Panthers
and the police was intense and at this
point you know the point he's giving me
this advice he knew it was already dead
for years so ok you and Johnny go back
to the house we gather ourselves and
eventually we go back to bed because
there's nothing to do all right
it's happened and we will find out the
night thing it's notjust not even
anywhere way to call anybody no no no
where to go right right so it's just
over yeah and so anyway and go back to
bed and the next day we get up and we
answer and Bob those Bob doesn't know
about Bob stay so let's to say this Bob
actually had gone
sorry Bob but no Bob Bob had gone to
give a talk I really hope it's ok to say
this I think it's public record I think
Bob has talked about it if he went to
the CIA the CIA was interested in his
work on deceit and self-deception and he
did not feel you know I don't think even
he loved the CIA but it was something I
felt like he was giving up any important
secrets in fact I mean he's published
his work on deceit himself design and
it's out there so
he before he left he he was very proud
of this joke that he would by lecturing
on deceit and self-deception to the CIA
he was taking coals to Newcastle the the
idea that the cops stole your your
lighter from you reminded me of one of
Bob's examples of self-deception in his
in his work on the subject in which he
reports that he is constantly stealing
lighters from himself himself bereft of
lighters right okay so let me try to
recall the order of events I think the
next thing that happens is its gonna be
the next morning you guys yeah I think
so I'm now closing in on my leave date
for Jamaica I have my ticket out and so
we're in the last couple days and I
think the next thing that happens is I
go I make a point of going to the jail
where Lexi has been taken to see him
because I'm not gonna see him otherwise
and he and I become friends and I just
didn't want to leave the island not
saying goodbye to him and so anyway I
whatever the jail was it was in one of
the town's not too far away you know 30
40 miles away maybe and somehow I maybe
I got uncle Vernie to drive me in Bob's
car as long as we're doing this let's
take this little detour so among the
many shocking lessons of my time in
Jamaica was that there was a kind of
inferiority complex
among Jamaicans about the capacity that
people that they saw coming from the US
and other mainland countries had right
there was a sense of inferiority but
from my perspective I was around people
who had tremendous ingenuity to be able
to do things when they didn't
necessarily have the right part right
you couldn't just source stuff and so
they were tremendously ingenious at
solving problems that in the States you
know you would bring your car somewhere
and they would just replace a part in
Jamaica they might have to fashion a
part or if they couldn't fashion a part
they'd have to clued some solution to
make the car run anyway and they were
constantly doing this and so anyway look
the opposite to me but there was
something about the razzle-dazzle nature
the you know the gadgets and techniques
and the ease with which things work when
you have exactly the right tool rather
than not exactly the right tool that had
left them with the wrong impression I'm
reminded of the story from our first
long trip to Central America with my
what 1976 Toyota Corolla and the trip
would have been in 1993 so this is you
know not a new car and I never had it
when it was new of course and the
alternator broke I mean so many things
broke on that car but the alternator
broke at one point we were still in
northern Mexico and we ended up flagging
down someone who had a ability to tow it
to the nearest place nearest town and we
said there's not going to be a new
alternator here right how long are we
stuck how long are we stuck in this we
don't even know where we are
you know northern central desert Mexico
and and the guy said are you kidding me
I rebuild them and at that point 93 I
think that was I can't read 91 that
would have been action anyone as well I
would've been right before you done you
then went to Jamaica with Bob you know
he laughed out it's like we don't we
don't use new office notice we rebuild
alternators and there was as far as I
know almost no one to rebuilding
alternators in the US at that right it
was it could be done but most people had
lost the skill no no in fact there was a
mechanism you would take your old
alternator in and you would get 10 bucks
back on your new alter name it was just
you know court charge all right and we
would rebuild it just on this little
little deviation here I don't remember
what he charged us in cash but it was
quite low but he also you know we had
the car completely packed because we
were gonna be on the road for the summer
and we didn't know where it was going to
take us and one of the things we had was
one of these like Costco sized cans of
almonds and so he asked for payment in
cash plus the almonds so yeah those
almonds that's the family size cost
thing elements yeah I still have those
almonds at least the can I'm sure the
can is being used yeah okay so anyway I
go and I see Lexie and the scene is a
little frightening actually Lexie is a
very robust dude mm-hmm but he's a
little shaken right and he's in a
concrete set the scene for the jail is
he is he alone in the south
in a cell it's kind of a big sell but
he's alone a cell it's concrete awful
mattress and not much more beyond that
but I talked to him I sit down with him
they let me in and I talked to him and
he tells me that they've got him
cleaning the marijuana that they're
lifting off of people of the stems and
the seeds so that they can resell it hmm
right so that's how corrupt this police
department and is he come to understand
that the at least the excuse the cover
story for them arresting him was because
he was in possession of marijuana oh no
no no no what I think the story was was
that a I don't even know why there was a
rival family I saw no evidence uh you
know I saw a little bit of interpersonal
conflict sometimes in Jamaica and it was
sometimes you know I learned
interpersonal conflict in Jamaica is a
bit louder than it is you know in the
u.s. usually but but anyway all of it
pretty good natured and and affectionate
so I wasn't aware that there was any
tension I never saw it but when clans
effectively right but somebody
apparently reported that the family I
was staying with had been involved in
some sort of a theft of goods from a
store which I guarantee you didn't
happen there were no goods yeah then
they wouldn't have done it right it was
just it didn't happen but they came
looking for that stuff
and having failed to find it and they
did find pot and that was technically
illegal they used it for elaborate or
something okay don't want to waste a
good suiting up into right here do not I
mean every time I've suited up in riot
gear I have made sure to find some sort
of an infraction to arrest people for
yeah okay so anyway I see Lexi we say
goodbye and I go back to South field and
there's an errand that bob has left I'm
just gonna ride along but I think it's
uncle Bernie has to go to the
to the hardware store to pick up some
funds for some workers who are working
on Bob's house that he's building down
there okay and so anyway
Vernie goes into the hardware store and
I'm sitting in the car and a Jamaican
guy seems nice enough comes up to the
window and asked me if I'm interested in
smoking a joint and this isn't so
unusual it's a little unusual
are you Bob's at CIA at this point are
you the only white guy I'm the only
white guy probably for 10 or 20 miles in
any direction okay so on the average day
the only other person of European
descent you see is Bob and he's not even
in country at this point right okay um
which is a very interesting experience
and among the many things I learned is
that that turns one of the tables but
not both of them right so it turns the
table of yeah you're actually the
minority and you feel it but the white
person is a powerful minority they're
understood to be powerful and you know
this has all kinds of implications that
I find profoundly disturbing like the
celebration of lighter-skinned children
but you know I'm an evolutionary
biologist I can also tell you why that
is the fact is in a world in which you
know there is something called white
privilege where something that would be
called white privilege if that term
wasn't being borrowed and abused
lighter-skinned children have
opportunities that others might not and
so you know it makes sense for people to
root for such things because it might
give you a leg up in situation where you
would otherwise not get anywhere so no
and the fact is that even when you are a
minority of one in your skin in a place
when your skin looks like yours or mine
you can always choose and at any moment
you may - you may choose to do just this
to go back to the place where you are
not the minority and you know I
experienced this in Madagascar we did as
well but the time that I was there
without you I really felt it very
acutely that okay it is yes whenever I
walk down the street I'm you know the
only white person for there you know
hundreds of miles
aside from Jessica my field assistant
and people are intrigued and enchanted
and scared horrified
and in northeast Madagascar one of the
myths is that the monster the demon that
comes and eats children comes in the
form of a white woman so occasionally
people like children are actually
deathly afraid because I've ever seen
one before and you know how that myth
started in a world without colonialism I
don't know yeah you know because you
know Madagascar is myths are far older
than the colonial influence of the
French but the fact is that at any
moment I could have left justice you
could have left and you did well what
brings me to the next part of story
excellent I'm sitting there in Bob's car
I've this guy has come out who I don't
know offer to smoke a joint with me yeah
I probably should have said no but I
didn't have a reason to say no and so he
gets in the car and he rolls a joint and
we're smoking it and he starts talking
to where I'm from and I you know I tell
him and I say you know he's I say I'm
headed back in a couple days and he
offers to get me a large amount of pot
to take back to the states and I say no
no thank you sir no thank you
he says are you sure and I say yeah I'm
sure I have no interest in that and
immediately cops in riot gear descend on
the car they yank him out of the car
they appear to rough him up and throw
him into the back of a vehicle at which
point they come to me and they pull me
out of the car and they start giving me
a very hard time alone here with uncle
Bernie
no uncle Bernie is in the hardware store
he doesn't see anything doesn't see any
of this okay so I'm out there the cop is
giving me a hard time and they start
searching the car I have no idea what's
in this car lots of people use this car
I don't know what's about to happen
right but anyway they search the car
they don't find anything and the cop
tells me that I am hanging out with the
wrong people and I say I don't think
they're the wrong people I think they're
very good people I really I think
they're excellent people I think you're
making mistake he said you're wrong you
are hanging out with the wrong people
and I say and he says and you have to
stop and I say I am leaving Jamaica in
two days and he said that's too long you
have to go tonight and then they drive
off with the guy who had tried to get
you to take a bunch of I tried to
yes.can out to agree to take pot I
believe I was being set up
yeah exam but in any case they drive off
and they tell me that I have to leave
tonight I don't really have a good
mechanism for even doing that right but
I more or less decide that's a bluff and
I return to the house and I you know do
what I was planning to do it tell I tell
your friends you told oh yeah oh yeah
tell everybody and anyway so I proceed
with my plans as they were scheduled and
I fly out without incident without
further and without further yeah not
entirely without incident I'm but an
Alexei Alexei is released
weeks later yeah I believe he spent a
good bit of time in jail for an offence
that was not an offence uh-huh that
nobody would have thought twice about
except the police doing unpaid work that
was itself part of the same offense
right yeah exactly so anyway that story
has a lot of depth to it and I guess
this is the the end of my public life so
anyway it's been great and
no that's I that's that's fabulous and
there are there are a lot more places to
go with that but I think it's it's
important to yeah I see why you didn't
want to go there with with Joe because
it's a long story
and you can definitely get dragged into
a lot of things that maybe you had you
had more important things to talk about
but the fact that you have experienced
you know abuse at the hands of police
and watched your friends be abused and
known that they were living a life that
they could not escape that at any moment
any of them and you know they weren't
you know I assumed yes you told me the
story at the time when you got back but
I assumed without asking but of course
they weren't roughing up women yeah you
can see that right and yeah I'm sure
there are occasionally women you know
maybe more so now who are involved in
what the police would view is nefarious
behaviors and some of them really are
and so sometimes they do you get roughed
up but in general it's gonna be you know
active riot geared police raiding houses
it's going to be men mostly young men
who are going to be treated badly yeah
and you you got off once may because
they didn't find anything maybe also
they weren't looking as hard because you
were white who knows well but I don't
know I mean I've thought a lot about
what this meant what they were hoping to
accomplish I can't really imagine that
they were gonna pin something on me and
I was gonna end up in a Jamaican prison
right if I'd been dumb enough to say
there's all your skin privilege this is
your nationality
right government would just not have
it's not well it might but it's not
worth the international incident so my
guess would be maybe I don't know maybe
they were hoping to extract some okay I
mean I don't I get the impression they
didn't catch the ones that I was there
until they happened on me unexpectedly
during their initial raid I sort of have
the sense that it was organic until that
moment and then something changed but
but I don't know there's something and
that's that's important to write that
the dehumanization of the people on the
other side be it the police or
whatever or you know or the protesters
or you know whatever group it is
actually requires that we imagine that
they have simple rules and that they
live by their pure principles at all
moments when in fact under times of
duress especially especially if not
perfectly trained as we know the police
worldwide not to be perfectly trained
there are going to be snap decisions
that aren't the ones that if you ask
them in in calm measured voices when
they aren't under duress what would you
do different decisions are made this is
when poor decision-making happens and
that's not an excuse or justification
but rather an explanation in part yeah
so I should say actually one of the
reasons I'm a little reluctant to tell
the story and I guess the deed is done
now is I certainly assume that you know
30 years later that there's no harm to
come from this those officers have long
since moved on presumably everybody gets
that the story is ancient history but I
really did value my time living in
Jamaica it gave me a window into yes how
Jamaicans live and how this particular
family lived but also just a correction
you know until you live in another
culture you only have your own
experience to go by and so this was so
eye-opening and so important as a
formative experience that I you know I
cherish it and and I I value all of the
interactions that I had and all the
people that I was living with who
treated me so well you know if in the
u.s. if you brought somebody into your
house study abroad like right you would
do your best to be gracious to them but
it would not be as warm and decent as
what I experienced among people who had
really no reason to care for me right at
some level they they cared for you both
because they loved Bob and they trusted
him and he wasn't bringing through a
whole host of people like you were he
didn't have a research assistant every
year like you were there working with
him that year
and I'm just totally guessing here but
you know maybe one year in five maybe he
would bring someone down to work with
him right so this was rare this wasn't
just a constant sort of circulating
tribe of random undergraduates from the
US but also you know you were real with
them and you were living in their home
and you were legitimately befriending
and you know enjoying the food and you
know not complaining about the fact that
you were showering with a bucket that
you had to dip into a pool like you know
I just like I've lived with you in those
situations and other places and I like I
know for sure you didn't complain you
know you know even if it wasn't you know
optimal but especially again you know
this is I think you were there for seven
weeks and it's everything for seven
weeks everything is still just amazing
even you know the legitimate hardships
of life where you don't have functional
running water or reliable electricity
and oh by the way the cops in riot gear
may suddenly show up when you're Dima
know the cops were present those things
are we'd live sexo okay
you were you were learning from every
single thing that you heard you were
doing down there you know this is this
is actually this is one of the things we
used to say to our students when we
would do study abroad is you know yes we
are going to be studying evolution and
ecology animal behavior and tropical
biology and philosophy of science you
know and statistics and all these things
but part of the reason to go is that we
are now going to be living in someone
else's culture among other people and we
we hope to you know we require that you
be respectful and understand that you
are guests in their culture and home but
we hope that you can manage to befriend
and you know learn to admire the
different ways that different people do
things and understand you know the ways
in which your life as Americans is
actually privileged and unique and the
ways that Americans got it wrong too
you know what have we lost with all of
the resources that we've got you know
this is something that was said to me
and to us in Madagascar a few times you
know the observation
from people that yeah you Americans
which nearly some very very few
Americans to the degree they saw any
vazha any white people it was mostly
French people you Americans seem to show
up with lots of stuff meaning we had
boots and backpacks like you know lots
of stuff meant just that we could you
know put shoes on our feet but you may
not have the family connections that we
have oh right and you you know there's
also an exchange of wisdom that I
thought was really profound so I recall
I often invoke uncle Bernie uncle Bernie
was a great guy as a mechanic yeah and
he was one of these guys who was just
you know super capable of figuring out a
solution when the thing that you you
know when they the a level solution
wasn't available he had you know B
through Z you know somewhere in his
arsenal but I remember one day I was
trying to I was trying to lubricate my
bicycle chain and I didn't have bike cam
lubricant and he brought me some corn
oil and I was like I'm not so sure he
said Bret the wrong lubricant is better
than no lubricant and to this day and
there's there's a couple of instances
where that's not true
I like the pawls of a ratchet but why
because if you put a lubricant that is
too thick they can stick but in most
cases you know there might be a best
lubricant but what you really need is
something to lubricate the things cuz
otherwise they rub together and and
terribly the apparatus apart but anyway
there's that but then there was also the
other thing which I found I still think
about it a lot which is there was this
gaggle of kids who ranged from very very
young like like three three yeah two
kids who were maybe you know 12 13 14
and they were they were really fond of
me because I would answer the questions
and they had a lot of bad information
coming to them a lot of it over you know
TV and stuff a bad info and American TV
is what they're being exposed to mostly
yeah now they find they find me
confusing because I frequently tell them
I don't understand what
asking me because they speak in patois
and my pathway is weak and they don't
even recognize the kids don't that they
too language because there's code
switching between school English and
patois and school English is not patois
it's that's American English it's
American English yes with a British
accent but but anyway it's so this
gaggle of kids was you know they were
constantly following me around and I
remember I was reading The Unbearable
Lightness of being I think was my book
the nervous reading yes and there was a
point at which I think it may be the end
of the book I hope I'm remembering this
correctly there's a scene where they
have to euthanize their own dog and I
knew I was gonna cry and I wanted to be
alone but this guy would not they would
not take the hint and so everywhere I
found a quiet place like kids would
descend so anyway yeah so what I don't
remember it was one of the kids or
someone else who asked you is the moon
that we see in Jamaica the same moon
that you see in the United States yeah
that was Prince it's a great question oh
yeah and it just it points you know
there's there's honest inquiry there and
you know unless you too can answer all
the questions on that list that you made
about why the seasons and why the
Solstice and why the two tides and all
of this yeah don't feel superior to
someone asking a question like that just
because that happens to be one of the
things that managed to get through
education you know get through to you in
education oh and especially you know I
remember being kind of dismayed at one
point I found a copy of the Weekly World
News mm-hmm and the problem is Weekly
World News looks like a newspaper
so he's telling its how its it was the
most ridiculous of okay you know and I
think the particular issue I was looking
at a woman had given birth to an otter
or something I mean just pure nonsense
right it's lizard people before its time
yeah exactly and so anyway you got just
garbagey information that in the u.s.
you would know to discount but it shows
up looking like a newspaper in a place
where they don't even have they're not
connected by phone so there's no way to
correct bad info
so but high literacy so you know that
something like that falls into people's
hands and they actually don't take it in
which it is actually you know
potentially a downside of literacy in a
place without good written word yeah you
don't we don't think of that downside of
literacy but but it potentially is one
but anyway so the thing you know for
instance question was a good one until
you know for sure I mean very distantly
separated places but there's you know it
led to several different discussions
because okay it's the same moon is the
phase the same right well if you think
about it why is the phase the same it
takes you a second to put together why
that would be and you know anyway we
could go down that rabbit hole and we
shouldn't but yeah well I think we are
over an hour already and there were many
other things that we wanted to talk
about them maybe we have not talked
about any of the horror and the world no
we haven't but maybe you know maybe we
should leave it well I have this one
quotation from James Baldwin that I
wanted to finish with but given that
we've gone for an hour and we'll be back
on Tuesday and we'll do a Q&A livestream
right after this you want to say just a
couple words let's just can we take a
quick show of hands are you guys alright
with that plan I was I guess I'll say
okay we'll save logistics for when
Zach's got the end screen up but so
James Baldwin who is extraordinary
writer and thinker was he's he's dead
now had this to say very short quote but
it seems like it it's a nice finish to
us talking about the solstice to begin
he says life is tragic
simply because the earth turns and the
Sun inexorably rises and sets and one
day for each of us the Sun will go down
for the last last time perhaps the whole
root of our trouble
the human trouble is that we will
sacrifice all the beauty of our lives
will imprison ourselves in totems taboos
crosses blood sacrifices steeples
mosques races armies flags nations in
order to deny the fact of death the only
fact we have
it seems to me that one ought to rejoice
in the fact of death ought to decide
indeed to earn ones death by confronting
with passion the conundrum of life what
is responsible for life it is the small
beacon in that terrifying darkness from
which we come and to which we shall
return
wow so that's that's Baldwin as
incredibly powerful it is all right on
that note so we have a just a couple
logistics things here we're going we're
going to pick up super check questions
as we always do from this hour
prioritizing by dollar amount and then
for the second half of the Q&A we will
look at super check questions that come
in in the next hour in the order that
they come in and we will miss some good
ones and for that we apologize but we
never have time to do all of them we
have created a what we're calling for
now Dark Horse membership on my patreon
a private Q&A a month for people who
sign up at the five-dollar level or
higher which it looks like I put a poll
up so unless a lot more people sign up
and change it looks like it's probably
going to be on the last Sunday of the
month this month on June 28th so if you
are interested in that you can go over
to my patreon sign up I feel like there
was something else but I'd forgotten
don't know well if we figure out what it
is we can pick it up at the beginning of
the livestream Q&A which will start in
about 15 minutes in the meantime be well
you